Okay, in your general considerations for specific cancers,
might as melanoma and liver, should we take all the supplements listed or just pick and choose.
So this person is asking these questions about the stock fighting cancer course.
And I can't answer specific cancer questions, but this is a course question.
So the very good question. So in the stock fighting cancer course,
we have different considerations of nutrition to take.
So I say consider this or consider that because I'm not making specific recommendations for a person
because they're not a full member. They're just looking at the course.
So it's a very good question. Should we take all the ones listed or just pick and choose.
I just ordered my genetic tests haven't got the results back.
Well, you're not going to get specific supplements to take for your cancer from the genetic test.
So remember, when we look at your genetics, we're looking at different SNP defects.
And that have to do with different metabolic pathways that may be wise to support nutritionally.
It may have to do with diet, may have to do with taking a supplement or something like that.
Because there's no research out there that if you have, let's say, an HNMT gene defect, which has to do with the ability to make the DAO enzyme in the tissue, which is the enzyme that breaks down histamine in the tissue.
And if you have a lot of defects on those HNMT genes, it might be good to support that even if you're not having a lot of symptoms.
So you could have a lot of defects in a specific gene, SNP family.
And you might not even have any symptoms because maybe they're not fully expressed, but it still might be a good idea to preventatively.
Oh, wow, I might take some nutritional antihistamine type things, maybe not on a daily basis, maybe a couple of times a week.
I might have those on hand, and I might take those on a pulsing type format, meaning you're not going to take them every day, but you might take them just on the weekend, or you might take them five days a week if you're having some symptoms.
So you might pulse some supplements, no way to have those defects are going to take these supplements, or no way to have those defects.
I'm going to maybe not gorge on histamine foods, you know, and I'm not going to eat a bowl full of nuts that contain a lot of histamines.
I'll just, you know, be a little bit more wise to my choices.
So when we look at your genetics, we're looking at those specific gene steps, and giving you some clues on some dietary things and nutritional things to support them.
They will not tell us about conditions, meaning I have cancer, or I have an autoimmune disease, or I have hypothyroid, you know, issues.
So genetics are going to show those things. So let's say I have, let's say I have melanoma, and I'm going to do my genetics is the genetic test going to tell me things that I should do for my melanoma.
No, is a genetic test going to give me some ideas of different pathways, different metabolic pathways that could be maybe, you know, a precursor to a disease.
Maybe, but certainly not going to give you treatment parameters for a specific disease. So be clear on that.
So if I get to try to quote unquote treat my melanoma naturally through our cancer course and look at some of the supplements that we suggested that you might want to consider.
Yes, you can pick and choose those things. So you can do all of them. You can do some of them. Everybody's different. Some people can't take a lot of stuff. Some people should take a lot of stuff. Some people are getting a lot of stuff in their diet because they're eating really well. Some people are dirty, really poorly.
So everybody's unique. And you're going to make your own decisions on that. So we're just giving you some advice that those are some of the things that tend to be good for that type of cancer.
There could be other things to try. When I wrote that piece to the course, I tried to kind of whittle it down to maybe some of the more important ones.
But yes, so that's a log answer to that question.